[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
نحن على عتابات موسم المربعانيه وهي من
اشهر مواسم الشتاء مدتها 40 يوما ولهذا
سميت بالمربعانيه تتكون من ثلاثه نجوم وكل
نجم 13 يوما ونصف المربعانيه 20 يوما وسم
من ناحيه التاثير ومن ناحيه الاجواء من
ناحيه الاجواء اجواء وها معتدله ومن ناحيه
التاثير اذا نزل مطر خلال 20 يوما فانه
ينبت ما ينبته الوسم فاول المربعانيه برد
خفيف وفي منتصف المربعانيه اطول ليال
السنه
باصباح وفي اخر المربعانيه برده
فان الليل قر والريح موقد ريح سر عسى يرى
كما يمر فان جلب الضيفا فانت
حر
وين المربعانيه من المواسم العدديه عند
العرب وهي ازمنه توقيتيه ومن اساسيات علم
الحسابي عندهم والمربعانيه سميت بهذا لام
مدتها 40 يوما والخمسينيه لام مدتها 50
يوما والسبع لان عدد نجومها 7 والاسبوع
لان عدد ايامه سبعه ايام والشتاء له بدايه
وشده ونهايه فبدايته مع المربعانيه وشدته
مع الشبط ونهايته مع العقارب البرد ما هو
رجفه يدين وعظام البرد برد الروح
غاليك
[موسيقى]